Google and Facebook are becoming more
and more black boxes the ability to you
know Target people in a very accurate
way like in the past does not exist
anymore that moves the uh needle into
the first party data so third party data
is pretty much dying it's still there
but it is dying and the way to
distinguish yourself is to leverage your
own first party data in order to make
smarter acquisition and smarter
retention welcome to 20 minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside FM Fusion VC Birthright Excel
J impact leap Google for startups and
hippo and in media partnership with ctek
[Music]
I'm very excited to have you here
talking about ad scale but overall your
entrepreneurial Journey serial
entrepreneur your previous company
sold to checkpoint and now you're in the
e-commerce advertising space and so a
lot to unpack here tell me a little bit
about you know your journey leading up
to ad space starting with your previous
startup how are you entering the ad
space
um you know Journey it's an interesting
story it was about what was it 2004 2005
with my previous company we died a sec
we had some
few first customers and somehow we
managed to have something like two
hundred thousand dollars in Saving we
felt like it's a lot of money
and we're saying now that's the title to
conclude the U.S market
uh hopefully she is obviously uh not
realistic but at that time we thought it
is so we hired a quite expensive
salesperson
uh I only paid him everything he asked
for and and basically he bought us
nothing so we will
with no money at that time to invest in
you know penetrating the U.S market
uh and then we said okay there's
something called Google there is Lionel
Edwards uh search ads let's just try
that
uh it was out of you know uh we were out
of options it was a cheap option so we
started you know playing without
advertising ourselves
and gradually we became better and
better and better and at a certain point
we got you know bands joining girls
system
uh rubber band from from Netherlands
from the internet like things that we
never expected
uh and then even Farm finally even
Jacobs even checkpoint found us over the
Internet when they looked for a
technology that we had at that time
so my experience at Diana SEC led me to
to you know to start with edskill
because we acquired so much knowledge
and so much you know understanding of
how uh advertising works that we thought
that we can use it in order to help
other people to advertise smartly uh we
started with with the non-ecommerce
world and then we thought that the
e-commerce is the most interesting niche
in that space and we decided to focus in
e-commerce advertising
okay so so tell me a little bit about
the product and how how it actually
works and the impact it makes an
organization so what is the the product
and the flow of it definitely so
um in general we help e-commerce
Merchants to to grow the business with
data-driven advertising with Automation
and with AI real AI
now I need to understand that uh
e-commerce advertising is is challenging
um
the Privacy protection regulations like
the gdpr the cccp and others created a
new world which is called a post cookie
world
in which the ability to track user
Behavior
is the is not like in the past no
um and the fact that you cannot use the
cookie which was the main you know
vehicle to track use of the behavior
ever since the internet was invented
is the huge change and requires us to do
uh different things
and in parallel we have the post covered
world that has jumped the competition in
the e-commerce world
and has jumped the customer acquisition
costs dramatically by tens of percent
sometimes even more
which brought many Merchants to to the
brink of profitability
so
um what we do we connect ethical connect
to the store
and we help them to very easily create
and manage ads across all the major
platforms Google Facebook Instagram even
SMS and email
by leveraging the store data into hyper
targeted campaigns we in the middle we
provide them with with the customers
with everything they need
to to boost ad performance this includes
um automated
ads creation
using a simple wizard automated
optimization on top of Google and
Facebook 24 7.
automated segmentation of customers in
order to to make advertising accurate
and even automated video Creations
directly out of their stores and even
automated ad copy by Licensing in
chargpt so everything is pretty much
automated you don't have to be a guru in
order to advertise like a pro you can
use ad scale and we will help you to get
the best results
you can get
two fantastic and so One Stop Shop for
the for the advertising needs and so how
you know the space is complicated right
I know that there's a lot of
organizations in the space so as a as an
advertising company how do you
differentiate or as an entrepreneur how
do you differentiate this company above
the noise uh the the in the attack space
so first of all the the fact that we
chose the e-commerce Niche already
differentiates us because there are no
too many you know players in the
e-commerce Niche or number one
competitor is either Google and Facebook
themselves or the you know media
agencies
but uh but still we definitely have
product differentiations uh
differentiators
I think that the fact that we use first
party data is the main differentiator
the fact that the market has changed
created the opportunity
uh Google and Facebook are becoming more
and more black boxes the ability to you
know Target people in a very accurate
way like in the past does not exist
anymore
and that moves the uh needle into the
first party data so third party data is
pretty much dying it's still there but
it is dying and the way to distinguish
yourself the way to do things better and
differently is to leverage your own
first party data in order to make
smarter acquisition and smarter
retention and we are the only software
today
that provides you in in one package
bi data like the data the acquisition
and the retention in one place all with
AI Nobody Does that you can like buy
three four five systems and you know and
and use them and hand over data from
system to system with Excel so or
whatever but uh I think that we are the
only ones that are using first party
data and all the other channels in one
place a all connected uh I think that's
that's what makes us unique
wonderful okay and so tell me a little
bit about this is a journey as an from
an entrepreneurial perspective what
things did you come into this journey
with that perhaps
um you know you changed or evolved as a
result of your previous experiences
yeah I thought about it previously and
um I think that my passion is in in
complexity like I like turning
complicated things maybe even abstract
things into a simple model into
something that we can manage something
we can control even something we can
optimize
now complexity you know makes life
interesting nobody wants to live in a
flat world
but we must learn the hidden
correlations between the different
components in order to control it
the challenge of you know connecting all
the dots together is something that
makes my work very interesting and and
it's common to to diet a sec where you
know my previous company where we took
you know the risk world and we help
organizations to assess the risk and to
make a gator risk and to calculate the
you know residual risk etc etc and to
what we do today that we take a very
abstract world with a lot of data and a
lot of channels and a lot of uh things
and noise in the middle and we try to
simplify that and to come to the
customer with a very simple system very
simple result of next next text that
helps you to build wonderful and very
profitable ad campaigns even if you're
not a guru or even if you never tried
advertising before so my challenge is in
taking the my passion is in taking the
complexity and turning it into something
simple and when we you know help people
to solve complex challenges with a
simple solution it makes me feel feel
good
and where so where are we heading from
an e-commerce in the e-commerce space
from an advertising perspective what's
what are you expecting over the next I
don't know uh three to five years
I think personalization will be a big
issue
the coffee the time created a situation
that all the big brands are heavily
invested in e-commerce
uh before the kovid I used to go to you
know big chains of of stores
and in many cases I heard something like
well it covers in terms of business is
just another branch
so there was any Commerce it's not
something new but not all of them
considered as e-commerce as something
very very critical there to the business
Corona changed the world you know upside
down and now everybody is doing
e-commerce in a very professional way
which means that the competition is high
and you need to distinguish yourself
when it comes to advertising the best
way to distinguish yourself is to go to
the basic
to see who are your customers to learn
their behavior to understand what they
buy when they buy what are the other
products that they might buy if they
only would know about it but but they
never go to your website never heard
about it
so you're missing in Opportunity so the
personalization is I think the main
a driver of of the growth for many
organizations and personalization comes
from the data that you have from your
customer data from your product data
from your other data from the ability to
understand which customer uh what is the
potential of each and every customer but
what is the stage of each customer is it
a new traffic that never visited your
website is it a remarketing customer
that you know visited your website but
never made any purchase is it a an
existing customer
and the second question is where do you
buy the you need to you need to play
smarter if it doesn't make any sense to
buy uh existing customers repeat
customers in Google and Facebook it's
just too expensive you already know who
are the people you have the name you
have the address you of the email you
have the phone you can use other methods
like SMS like email to bring them back
in a much cheaper way and by that you
can create a custom acquisition course
that makes sense
Google or Facebook are still and for the
forecast for for what I can forecast
will still be for the next years the
best way to acquire new customers but
when it comes to
acquire existing customers I don't think
it it makes sense to buy them over there
they are cheapest ways to do it and if
you can do it all together personalize
your marketing and Advertising based on
data
and then then I think that's the way
forward I mean just to give you and to
give you the situation in numbers uh if
in the past we used to tell customers
listen you need at least five six seven
maybe ten
segments to you know have a professional
advertising and marketing today we talk
on we talk about 30 or 40 even 50 or 60
micro segments in order to make the
advertising more accurate more
personalized I think that's the way
forward
very very interesting and so
you know is there sort of a unanimous
agreement amongst you know thought
leaders in the in the attack and the
e-commerce space around am I what you're
saying or is there are there different
points of view or some controversy
around it everybody speaks from position
you know how is it in life yeah of
course uh so so definitely the the
mobile views
um
I think that what we are saying is that
the world of Drop Shipping
is declining like in the past you know I
mean if we look at Ecom as the beginning
e-commerce or techies that had great you
know excellent technical skills and
started selling over the internet and
that was basically e-commerce
and today when we look at e-commerce
then we have the brands and we have the
drop shippers and the brands are going
you know much faster
um
some people think that the the the
future is in in marketplaces
um
I cannot argue about it you know
marketplaces
are with us for 20 years and I don't
think it's going to be changed
dramatically but I do think that Brands
will strength the e-commerce presence
because it makes the financials looks
much better if you can use e-commerce
next to your you know brick and motor
business and do what we call omnichannel
and use data from the brick and mortar
to the e-commerce and from the equals to
the brick and mortar this combination I
think makes businesses much stronger and
I think that's the path forward but
I respect any other idea or any other
thoughts or opinion
um I think it's such an interesting it's
such an interesting space that you're in
and I think that the end a lot of it is
coming down also to human to to human
psychology and human computer
interaction which are fields that I'm
personally very um very interested in
you know if I I think one of the one of
the big parts that that I love about
this show is also dissecting a little
bit as to you know why do people do what
they do and what is
um you know what what really is Drive
what really drives people especially
entrepreneurs because it's kind of a
crazy journey to go on so I'd love to
hear a little bit from you why why is it
that you do what you do you know what
drives you mati I'm an alcoholic and I
like to create things and and other
entrepreneur in my soul so I
always fulfilled to take the you know
the the hard way
and not the easy way that's ever since I
was a child
um so besides the you know the the
economic and financial things that
drives every entrepreneur or main most
of them I believe in certainly me
um I like to bring something new to the
table and when you're entrepreneur you
mainly meet yourself you mainly wait
your limitations you may limit the
points where you can develop and you
mainly learn how to take yourself out of
the comfort zone so many times that you
almost feel Comfort to take yourself out
of the comfort zone and I just I just
love being you know in an unstructured
environment
uh places that are too structured out
just simply not for me I like to start
with something abstract and build
something out of that that's that's my
passion that's my life and that what
drives me
and so if you're looking at it from a
from a you know interpersonal
perspective on a leadership side what is
your what is your own leadership take on
the people that you work with and then
how you manage them on on building a
culture yeah
people is is an interesting story
because
um
[Music]
when the time goes by you you learn more
and more all the people that you need
next to you and it's it's so different
than what I thought in the past
I think that I like working with with
people that first of all can help me
take my you know complicated ambitious
and my abstract ideas and and to turn
them into practical steps that we can
Implement now
it means that I'm looking for people in
in the combination of of a can-do
attitude on one hand for sure but people
that have you know one foot in the
reality and and
um and one foot in the dreams and I
think that the balance between the two
is is critical so I'm looking for people
that are much better than me in their
domain expertise but also with the
ability to to dream not just to say okay
that's what we know that's what we learn
that's what we'll do for the rest of our
life and I like people that like to take
the challenges on one end but still to
be realistic and practical and to
balance me because I'm a dreamer so I
need people to balance me and to
translate the wishes into practical
things that can be done
tomorrow we can start doing them
tomorrow and these are the people that I
like and that that's my leadership style
I uh I listen to to everyone
um I I try as much as I can but always
I'm successful with that to be honest
but I try as much as I can not to
completely Prejudice to no let all your
opinions and come in and and and and to
think about it and let it float but uh
in the end of the day once we get a
decision I really like everybody to be
committed to the decision and not to you
know criticize the decision we think
together but once we make a decision
we're all committed so I have the
balance between the two between the
dreams and between the Practical things
that needs to be done after all we have
to be a profitable company and and and
you need to find that balance and it's
it's not easy it's not easy
best of luck on on your personal journey
of at skill and any other company that
you that you create and I have a feeling
it's not the last one so thank you again
for the time and the energy and I really
look forward to seeing this develop from
the side so thank you very very much
take your bike it was a pleasure foreign
[Music]